thanks to Skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learned to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the doobly-doo I'm
trying to be cool about this but you
can't just root peoples music off it's
just a long I'm a record company above
the law I've never heard anything like
that
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are covering the
episode of South Park that gave rise to
the Chewbacca defense this is probably
one of the most quoted things buying
lawyers in the entire world and it's
great to go back and see the genesis of
the Chewbacca defense because my friends
and I use it all the time why would an
eight-foot-tall wookie want to live on
Endor with a bunch of two-foot tall he
wants that does not make sense as always
be sure to comment in the form of an
objection which I'll either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where i give the South Park
chef a Chewbacca defense episode a grade
for legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in to South Park chef aid okay
so the background here is that chef
wrote a song called called stinky
britches
that's all 20 years ago and now it's
being covered by major rock artists
including Alanis Morisette so because he
wrote the song he goes to the record
company to ask that he be credited for
having written the song he actually
doesn't ask for monetary compensation he
just wants a credit for having written
the song stinky britches mr. stinky
britches was something I wrote several
years ago hmm I really see no
resemblance between that song and stinky
britches by our artist Alanis Morissette
I don't think that's the kind of song
that Alanis Morissette would write also
I don't know how people are able to
determine that this is the same song
given just the two seconds of a song
that they're playing and that it shares
really this this lyric I mean presumably
this song is exactly the same so I think
we can we can understand that it is
supposed to be the same song but I
understand that in the real world just
because the same lyric is in multiple
songs does not necessarily mean that
copyright infringement has occurred I'm
trying to be cool about this but you
can't just real peoples music off it's
just a long I'm above the law a record
company above the law I've never heard
anything like that mr. chef I'm afraid
you leave me no alternative we're going
to sue you sue me you stole one of my
selves and you're gonna sue me yes I
suggest you get a real good lawyer we'll
have the best in the business
we'll get my dad to be chefs lawyer yeah
he's Jimmy God okay so that might sound
insane that someone wrote a song that a
music label then copied that song and
the music label sues the person who
originally wrote the song there is
actually a real mechanism in real life
that would allow that to happen there's
something called declaratory relief that
allows someone that once a controversy
has occurred to then go to court and
while they are effectively the plaintiff
really what they're doing is saying I'm
worried that this other person is going
to sue me or that there is some
controversy that needs to be adjudicated
and as a result I'm going to take the
affirmative step of filing suit and just
adjudicating this thing so while it
might seem crazy that the the victim
could be the defendant in a lawsuit like
this it's actually totally plausible
that the music company might be so
worried about this lawsuit that they
take the affirmative step of filing suit
against chef and the mechanism that they
would be using is called declaratory
relief so it actually could happen
you know I actually don't think that
that Alanis Morissette stinky britches
song sounds like the one that chef sang
earlier on in this episode of course
we've seen in the news recently that
there have been some major copyright
infringement actions between songs that
I don't think sound anything like each
other and frankly I think the jury's got
it wrong for example we saw in the
blurred lines Marvin Gaye lawsuit and
the Katy Perry Dark Horse lawsuit both
of which the juries found for the
plaintiff I don't think that there is a
really good reason why that should count
as copyright infringement I've been
meaning to do a video on this but in the
meantime check out Adam Neely's videos
on these subjects he's done a really
good job of breaking down the lawsuits
from a music theory perspective and I
think my hunch is right that these
lawsuits should not have held for the
plaintiff let alone penalize the
defendants by millions of dollars now
just let me do all the talking chef's
we're gonna bring these down right this
Court is now in session who is
representing the defense I am your honor
gerald brovlofski and representing the
prosecution I am your honor
Johnnie Cochran Oh Oh chef that's
Johnnie Cochran he's the guy who got OJ
off uh-oh all right so for the younger
viewers out there that is true that
there was a famous lawyer named Johnnie
Cochran who was the lead counsel in the
OJ Simpson murder trial Oh Jay Simpson
for those of you that don't remember was
a star football player and was alleged
to have murdered his wife and his wife's
lover famously OJ Simpson had many
different lawyers but the most famous
and lead counsel was Johnnie Cochran who
was well known for coming up with
phrases that would be repeated
throughout the trial when I covered the
Seinfeld finale that involved a trial
they also created parody of Johnnie
Cochran whose name was Jackie childs who
exhibited similar flamboyance in court
I am shocked at your grin I think we're
gonna see a lot of some parodies of
Johnnie Cochran in the South Park trial
and so on this 15th day of what is
considered to be the most important
trial of the
a Johnny Cochran has appeared to defend
capitalist records the question now is
will Cochran use his famous Chewbacca
defense so famously for some reason the
OJ Simpson trial they allowed cameras
inside of the courtroom and it just
turned into this phenomenon that the
entire nation was obsessed with I
actually remember in middle school I
think we stopped classes we rolled in a
TV into the classroom and we watch the
verdict being read because we knew it
was going to be a historical event and
as a result the news coverage about the
OJ Simpson trial and of course the
chef's trial in this particular case
we're just insane and there were cameras
and talking heads it was really sort of
the beginning of the cable news sort of
pundit read that we see today
that's what Cochran used in the OJ
Simpson trial I hate that Kathryn get in
front of me yeah so what Cartman has
done here is a pretty good parody of
what I see all the time on Twitter which
is people who don't have a law degree or
any experience in the legal profession
second-guessing seasoned professionals
and so in summation ladies and gentlemen
of the jury oh okay we're already in
summation for some reason apparently the
trial was the next day and we're
starting with closing arguments instead
of actually going through the trial and
there is no discovery this kind of trial
would take conservatively two years to
get to trial if it even got to trial and
99% of cases do not even get to trial
they settle or they are dismissed early
on and they come nowhere near the actual
courtroom or a jury so this is very very
wrong very wrong you've heard the
version of my clients song recorded over
20 years ago
you've heard the exact same song
produced by these cheats in the past
months I'd say it's pretty much an
open-and-shut case make the right
decision thank you and you know if you
had a very strong case and you really
thought that the two songs sounded
identical to each other there's no
reason that your closing argument needs
to be particularly fancy you could just
play them
back-to-back or next to each other and
that might be very persuasive evidence
but again if you had a very strong case
it's very unlikely to get to trial
that's actually one thing that people
often forget about trials is that only
marginal cases go to trial and that's
both on a civil level and a criminal
level because it has to be a really
close call otherwise it would not get to
that point in the judicial system so
when you have an open-and-shut case it's
gonna be dealt with long before you ever
get to trial mr. Johnnie Cochran your
closing arguments ladies and gentlemen
of the suppose that Jerry was supposed
to jury they want you to believe that
his client wrote stinky britches ten
years ago and they make a good case hell
I almost felt pity myself but ladies and
gentlemen of this supposed jury I have
one final thing I want you to consider
ladies and gentlemen this is Chewbacca
Chewbacca is a Wookiee from the planet
Kashyyyk
but Chewbacca lives on a planet Endor
it's true nothing about it that does not
make sense damn it well he's using the
Chewbacca defense so this is a parody of
Johnny Cochran's famous saying during
the OJ Simpson trial if it doesn't fit
you must acquit now in the actual OJ
Simpson trial there was a bloody glove
found at the crime scene both the
prosecution and defense made a very big
deal about this particular bloody glove
and in one of the biggest blunders of
all time as prosecutors the prosecutors
had OJ Simpson take the stand even
though he was taking the fifth as to
everything else and they had him try on
the glove now they gave him plenty of
forewarning to know that he was going to
be asked to put it on and he wore a
latex glove underneath the leather glove
as he was trying to try it on so he had
time to you know bulk up his hand and he
had the ability to sort of spread out
his fingers and he was wearing a latex
glove too so as to not contaminate it
and for all of those reasons the defense
said that the glove didn't fit Oh Jay
Simpson and so the defense made a huge
deal out of this in the closing argument
and people make fun of Johnnie Cochran
for this childish saying that if the
glove doesn't fit you must acquit but
the thing is
it sticks with you even now 20 years
later we're still talking about this
particular defense and it stuck with the
jury too I think it's actually a stroke
of brilliance that Johnnie Cochran was
able to capitalize on this bad fact the
prosecution miss played their hand no
pun intended and lo and behold the jury
did in fact find that OJ Simpson to be
not guilty so that is the underlying
real-life thing that actually happened
that gave rise to this parody version
that you bought a defense why would it
look an eight-foot-tall rookie want to
live on indoor with a bunch of two-foot
tall Ewoks that does not make sense but
more importantly you have to ask
yourself what does this have to do with
this case nothing ladies and gentleman
it has nothing to do with this case it
does not make sense look at me I'm a
lawyer defending a major record company
and I'm talking about Chewbacca yeah
does that make sense
ladies and gentlemen I am NOT making any
sense none of this makes sense and so
you have to remember when you're in that
jury room deliberating and conjugating
the Emancipation Proclamation does it
make sense no ladies and gentlemen of
this supposed church it does not make
that it's you bakken lives on Endor you
must acquit okay so there are a lot of
problems with this particular theme and
there's this parody of the the OJ
Simpson's glove defense number one
Chewbacca
I think was on Endor for you know like
the Battle of Endor and I don't know
that he actually lives on Endor he you
know goes around the galaxy with Han
Solo so I'm not even sure it's accurate
to say that Chewbacca actually lives on
Endor he's from cachaca obviously but
let's put that aside and let's focus on
the actual legal issues and not the Star
Wars implications I'm sure I'm gonna get
tons of comments about how I don't even
understand the Star Wars extended
universe this is just non sequitur after
a non sequitur it's literally trying to
take something that doesn't make sense
and saying for no reason whatsoever that
if that doesn't make sense that this
jury should not find in favor of chef
the defense wrist okay then so yeah even
the judge recognizes that it's total
gibberish and makes no sense whatsoever
and
just because it doesn't make sense that
doesn't actually give a reason for why
the jury you should find for the
plaintiff in this particular case but
that being said it has made a huge mark
on lawyers in general my friends and I
will often say we are using the
Chewbacca defense or that opposing
counsel is using the Chewbacca defense
when they're doing something that
doesn't make any sense at all
doesn't really work judges don't like it
juries don't believe it and it doesn't
doesn't work out the way you think it
would I'll find you the jury we find the
defendant to Rome chef McElroy guilty as
charged
and that doesn't even make any sense
because this is a simple case this is a
simple case for a declaratory relief
it's not even a criminal case where you
could find someone guilty you can't find
someone guilty in a civil case you would
have to have a criminal case for that
mr. chef you've been found guilty of
harassing a major record label harassing
the full fee of 2 million dollars will
be handed over within 24 hours do I look
like I have two million dollars well you
have 24 hours to find it or else you
have to go to jail for 8 million years
also not a thing yeah ok so a number of
things are very wrong here number one
you can't sentence someone to go to jail
in a civil case you can't find them
guilty in a civil case what chef was
doing was in no way harassment and
wouldn't even be grounds for anything
like that on top of that you wouldn't be
given a choice between going to jail and
paying a huge fine even if it was a
criminal case and frankly this is
probably one of the biggest issues in
civil law is that if there was a
judgment for two million dollars against
some poor individual who's just a chef
at a local school
they're not gonna be able to pay that so
they effectively be judgment proof and
they just file for bankruptcy and
discharge the debt that is owed and that
chair - I want that chair you heard the
judge since he lost the case I can seize
whatever I want to pay my legal fees
yeah take that water cooler - so while
this timeline is totally unrealistic
what is actually realistic is sometimes
if you have a judgment in court you can
use that to get all of the things of the
person who the debt is against or you
can get a wage garnishment so that if
they have a salary you can get a
percentage sometimes
very high percentage of that salary in
order to pay back the debt that is owed
and in order to get the court to sign
off on turning over physical property
you would need something called a writ
of attachment which is something that
would happen in the months after the
trial saying that you are owed this
judgment and the only way to get it is
to basically take the physical
possessions of the defendant or the
plaintiff in this case the funny thing
is if you're able to get a writ of
attachment you get the sheriff of the
the city or the municipality to enforce
it so law enforcement will actually go
to the house of the person against whom
you have a judgment and they will help
you take all of the things and make sure
that the the person is not trying to
stop you so presumably in this
particular case there would have been a
writ of attachment and the physical
goods would have been sold to discharge
the debt it's a real thing ladies and
gentlemen of this supposed Jail you must
now decide whether or not to reverse the
decision from my client chef's I know he
seems guilty but ladies and gentlemen
this is Chewbacca okay hold on before
Johnny Cochran gets into the second
Chewbacca defense let's think like a
lawyer there's no such thing as a jury
reversing the decision of another jury
that there's a principle in the law
called race judicata that says once a
case is determined that's it it's done
and in the case of a jury trial you
might be able to get the appeals court
to weigh in and say that there was some
defect from a legal perspective but you
would never be able to get a second jury
on exactly the same factual matter to
render another factual decision that's
absolutely not allowed at all once the
facts are settled they're settled
nothing about that for one minute that
does not make sense why am I talking
about Chewbacca when a man's life is on
the line why I tell you why I don't know
it doesn't make sense if Chewbacca does
not make sense you must acquit here look
at the monkey look at the silly monkey
it's it's totally unrealistic but it's
really funny
[Music]
all right now it's time to give the
South Park Chewbacca defense episode a
grade for legal realism on the one hand
this episode sort of hints at things
that you don't really see in legal
dramas very much like writs of
attachment and declaratory relief where
a defendant Sousa plaintiff that's
really cool that doesn't happen very
often and the Chewbacca defense has been
adopted by lawyers everywhere we use it
all the time on the other hand is
basically everything else the timing is
all screwed up the second trial makes no
sense at all the legal arguments are
intentionally insane so I'm gonna have
to give this episode of South Park a
c-minus for legal accuracy it really
needs to go back to South Park I now you
can only get sued by the music industry
if you have a song first so if you want
to learn how to make your own hit song
that will be covered by Alanis
Morissette and then be subject to a
multi-million dollar lawsuit you'll
first need to learn how to mix and
produce your own songs to do that I'd
recommend young guru Skillshare course
learn how to mix music with DJ young
guru he covers everything you could
possibly want to know about making music
including organizing the mix tweaking
the levels and adding effects he can't
keep you from getting sued by capitalist
Records but he can't help you make a
diss track sound awesome awesome awesome
awesome awesome insane Skillshare is an
online learning community that has
nearly 30,000 classes on everything like
music design technology and business
legal eagles will get two free months of
Skillshare when you click on the link
below plus it really helps out the
channel the free premium membership
gives you unlimited access to must know
topics so you can improve your skills
and learn new things all free for two
months so take young guru skill share
class and start making your own stinky
britches do you agree with my grade
leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other real lawyer
reactions over here where I will see you
in court